bro bro bro i just read this today by
buzzfeed on demi lovato demi lovato's
pronouns are now she her and she
explains why she changed them back
for me it's just about like feeling
human at your core
she went from she hard to they them
uh whatever it is then back to she her
and these people just be changing
pronouns like they [ __ ] underwear in
may of last year demi came out as
non-buyers that she would be using they
them pronouns in a recent interview on
spouse podcast demi revealed that she
now uses she her pronouns and she
explained why she made the update
mental health
you're bringing me state you're bringing
stigma to mental health stop no stigma
no none no stigma
mental health demi said
before she refers to herself as a fluid
person
we're not covering this
we're not covering this
you know what i think with all these
people i feel like their careers are not
doing that great so they just started
saying this goofy issue i heard is more
than that okay is it yes i don't know
much about her what do you mean there's
there's there's mental health mental
health sure mental health yeah
google it rob spasm and now i know like
okay that word is hypothetically
hypothetically i know somebody right
they come to me they say you know what
my pronouns are no longer she her
they're the either look you know me i'll
be honest with you i'm not gonna use it
i'm not gonna pronounce but i'll use her
name yeah i'll be like hey peter
that's gender neutral okay peter could
be a she could be a hero name is jenny
neutral now if you start telling me all
right my parents are now he she he him
okay i'm like okay sure and then you
start changing back to like lay them and
then just change back like i'm like bro
figure out your pronouns whatever you
gotta do i'm just gonna use your name
i'm not gonna engage in this kind of
nonsense yeah i'm saying like some
people i feel like it's just
unnecessary am i crazy for saying that
but the thing is
go ahead the thing is when you're fluid
it's a mood
it's it's it's a move it's like deep
game deep game
peep game big game
it's like so [ __ ] up you said it's a
move it's a mood and you know what i
heard right what
my mind's telling me no
why was that on your mind
because it's a mood
it's
stupid she's stupid
this guy's stupid
i can't do this
am i nobody imagine you know when you
miss gender so when you misgender when
you misgender someone you get in trouble
it's like getting in trouble for saying
oh hi how you doing you you look you
look looking good today and you're like
no i look like [ __ ]
because i feel like [ __ ]
that's the mood
you feel like
you feel like [ __ ] but i'm getting in
trouble because i thought you look good
that's a bit that if you feel one day
that you're broke i'm not going to ask
you every day
what your pronouns are if you're fluid
i'm saying if you're i'm not going to
ask every day what's your pronoun yeah i
mean but i'm going to call you by your
name
if it's too hard for me to
again if you're fluid only if you're
fluid
if it's too hard to to keep track i'mma
call you by the name so that's like i
feel like that's a big uh compromise
between not compromise but for me it's
like name change you get one after that
we're not doing no more peter
you want to go from peter to shop azula
the third okay
if you want to go from sakazu the third
to whatever it is no we're not doing
that
i'll lose you as a friend i don't give a
[ __ ] same thing with kanye
or or puff daddy we at some point we
stopped you got hong kong puffy cone
puff daddy pee diddy pop dada dooby
father stop
okay same thing with kanye kanye west
kanye kanye
yeah
yeah okay yeah that dude
yeah
that dude we're not we're not following
another one
you know what i was thinking when you
said puff daddy i think everything like
daddy would [ __ ] his son's girlfriend
that's the only new title i accept
god damn you've been watching a lot of
people lately no no he really did [ __ ]
his whole
isn't uh
what am i crazy huh
i might have misspoke [ __ ] i don't think
i did you're talking about look it up
oh well unless you're justin combs 25
who's a dad rapper and entrepreneur char
and diddy combs 49 is reportedly dating
justin's ex-girlfriend lori harvey yeah
but it's lori harvey everybody dated
laurie harvey yay okay so you're saying
i don't mean [ __ ] she's like hot
potatoes
potato potato potato potato hot potato
she was not now she settled down you
know
who
isn't she with uh michael b woohoo
michael jordan they're not together no
more
they're not together no more everybody
was talking about look at this reformed
are you sure google it
they don't have they don't have it they
don't have it they don't have potato but
they don't have it they don't have it
they don't have it they
this is crazy this is such an unexpected
topic you went from we've never done
this
[Music]
this is crazy bro
i didn't even think we're going to cover
this this is so [ __ ] random
yo shout out to laurie harvey man she
did her community activism within the
rich people's fear unparalleled i'm mad
at it yeah she dated everybody do your
thing [ __ ] yeah live your life let us
know what you guys think about today's
topic
whatever it is